Within an organism, each
non-reproductive cell contains all of
the DNA of that organism. This DNA
encodes all the proteins made in the
organism.
But if all cells have all of the DNA,
how do different cells do different
things? How does a brain cell make only
the proteins needed for a brain to
function correctly, but not the
proteins that are only needed in a
muscle? So how does a cell decide which
genes it should express and which it
should not? The answer: transcription
factors.
Transcription factors are proteins that
scan along the DNA, looking for
specific DNA sequences to bind. Once
they find and bind their specific DNA
target, they change shape and can
interact with or recruit other
proteins.
Through this binding and interaction
with other proteins, these
transcription factors can increase,
turn on, or decrease, turn off, the
expression of specific genes.
The main way they do this is to promote
or block the recruitment of RNA
polymerase, the enzyme that transcribes
DNA into RNA.
If the transcription factor promotes
the recruitment of RNA polymerase, it
is helping to turn that gene on. In
this case, RNA polymerase will bind
more easily and frequently to the gene
to which the transcription factor is
associated.
This results in an increase in
the amount of RNA produced from that
gene. However, if the transcription
factor blocks the recruitment of RNA
polymerase, it is helping to turn that
gene off. Therefore, RNA polymerase
will not bind as easily or frequently
to the associated gene and there'll be
little or no RNA produced from that
gene in this cell.
Since the amount of RNA produced by RNA
polymerase is usually related to the
amount of protein made, transcription
factors help control which genes are
expressed in which cells, and therefore
helps cells perform specialized
functions.